und noch eine gute nachricht oder eher
eine schlechte nachricht wenn man die
zahlen anschaut viele menschen sind
nicht an corinna gestorben wir müssen
ihnen einmal diese seite eins heute in
bild zeigen das ist nämlich eine
erkenntnis die vieles verändert in
dieser krise die vieles verändern könnte
in dieser krise wenn man sich das mal
ganz genau anschaut viele tote starben
nicht an corona problem aber sie fallen
genau in die statistik mit rainer
schauen wir uns einmal an unserem tisch
genauer ansagen einmal zuviel appeared
hoffen bevor jetzt an ihr vorbeilaufen
sagen wir einmal hallo du hast nämlich
diese geschichte hier recherchiert wir
schauen das ist einmal gleich genauer an
anhand von drei bundesländern für uns
einmal kurz auf was genau bedeutet dass
viele monate sind gar nicht an corona
gestorben man sieht das immer man sagt
immer menschen die mit oder an cholera
gestorben sind es sagt kommt einem so
schnell über die lippen dahinter liegt
aber das problem dass eine zahl in eine
statistik mit einfließen die das so
eigentlich korrekt also gar nicht dürfte
genau das wird gesehen als die härteste
währung in der korona pandemie die
anzahl der korona toten die wird vom rkw
beispielsweise täglich ausgewiesen und
wir haben alle gesundheitsministerien
der länder gefragt und wollten wissen
wie viele der menschen die als corona
tote vermeldet werden sind denn an
cholera gestorben spricht todesursache
cupid 19 und wie viele sind mit corona
gestorben sprich die todesursache war
nicht fit 19 und da kam raus dass das
sehr schwanken die zahlen sind in
manchen ländern bundesländern sachsen
anhalt beispielsweise ist jeder dritte
der als corinna tote gemeldet wurde gar
nicht an corinna gestorben sondern mit
gewonnen da schauen wir uns genau an
denn darin steckt ja auch die wahrheit
dass die todeszahlen sowie sie
ausgewiesen werden nicht so hoch sind
wie bisher angenommen
absolut denn es braucht hier transparenz
genau wie bei allen anderen zahlen und
man merkt ein weiteres mal dass alles
was mit zahlen und daten zu tun hat also
all das worauf wir eigentlich täglich
angewiesen sind um zu schauen wie
schlimm es um die pandemie steht welche
maßnahmen wir brauchen alles was mit
zahlen zu tun hat wird von der
bundesregierung verfälscht oder
übertrieben oder sehr auch unpräzise
einfach und präzise wiedergegeben obwohl
die zahlen ja da sind das möchte ich
gleich in richtung aller
verschwörungstheoretiker sagen wir haben
da nichts großartiges aufgedeckt was
irgendwo im verborgenen lag sondern wir
haben die gesundheitsministerien der
länder angefragt und viele bundesländer
etwa die hälfte erfasst diese zahlen sie
können trennen zwischen ancona
gestorbenen und mit corinna gestorbenen
es wird nur nicht so transparent
veröffentlicht wie es eigentlich sein
sollte zwar alles nach märz aber hier
ist es angekündigt und jetzt gehen wir
über zu unserem touch ich nehmen sie mal
wird der philips rücken einer hinweg
denn diese zahlen wollen wir uns anhand
dreier bundesländer einmal genauer
anschauen wir sagen immer die menschen
die mit oder an corona gestorben sind
das ist aber etwas was sie zahlen
durchaus beeinflusst schauen wir uns das
einmal in bayern an hier besprechen vom
zeitraum seit dem ersten dezember 20 21
bis mitte januar wir sehen zu diesem
zeitpunkt sind
1832 menschen mit oder an corona
gestorben werden ausgewiesen als corona
tote schauen wir uns das aber einmal
genauer an wenn man bei den
gesundheitsministerien nachwuchs so
sieht man todesursache corona waren 84
prozent und dann gibt es zwei bereiche
in eine andere todesursache sind elf
prozent oder eine unbekannte
todesursache sind fünf prozent das
bedeutet dass diese insgesamt 16 prozent
von menschen die zwar mit corona im
krankenhaus lagen aber nicht daran
gestorben sind aber eben genau in diese
zahl hier drüben einfließen und das ist
der grund warum diese zahl im prinzip
nicht korrekt dargestellt ist wir wollen
uns das noch mal ein weiteren beispielen
in anderen bundesländern anschauen wer
jetzt beispielsweise
rheinland pfalz auch hier ist es so
todesursache corona 83 prozent es wurden
272 tote corona tote ausgewiesen 17
prozent sind aber an einer anderen
todesursache gestorben lagen also mit
corona im krankenhaus sind aber nicht
daran gestorben und damals bereits
angesprochen besonders drastisch sieht
man dass hier in sachsen anhalt schon
auf diese zahl
1455 corona tote so heißt es dann denkt
man diese menschen sind natürlich an
cholera gestorben aber auch hier wieder
dieser feine unterschied an oder mit
corona deswegen der wichtige blick
hierauf eine andere todesursache
verzeichnen 29 prozent und 7 gar eine
unbekannte todesursache das bedeutet
eben auch wieder dass diese zahl hier
mit in die
offiziell ausgewiesenen corona toten mit
einfließt und damit gebe ich jetzt
zurück zu viel pathos und teilweise
ja und philipp natürlich die wichtige
frage zu stellen was machen wir jetzt
mit dieser erkenntnis was macht die
regierung was macht die politik mit
dieser erkenntnis die müsst ihr euch
sofort daher kalt gehen der
gesundheitsminister vor allen dingen und
die gesundheitsminister der länder und
müssen sagen das korrigieren wir ab
sofort ab sofort arbeiten wir mit ja
andere zahlen weisen das ganz
transparent selbst aus tja schön wärs
keine schön wär's wir sind jetzt fast
zwei jahre in dieser pandemie und es ist
auch schon sehr lange bekannt dass diese
zahlen und präzise und zum teil
verfälscht ausgewiesen werden und es
wird noch immer nicht in allen
bundesländern so erhoben manche
bundesländer haben mir mitgeteilt sie
hätten keine daten sie würden nicht
differenzieren zwischen an und mit
corona verstorbenen oder das sei sehr
schwierig festzustellen andere
bundesländer haben sofort ihre daten
geschickt als wäre das eine absolute
selbstverständlichkeit und damit zeigt
dass es ist ja möglich daß so
auszuweisen warum weiß man das nicht so
aus jetzt gerade eben als wir das amt
auch nochmal dargestellt haben es ist
jetzt zumindest eine unterteilung an
andere todesursache und unbekannte
todesursache möglich warum weiß man das
nicht ganz genauso aus warum erheblich
daten sagen diese menschen sind mit
corona im krankenhaus gestorben und
diese menschen sind an kuren einem
krankenhaus gestorben das ist ja eine
entscheidende unterschied beträgt hier
das ist genau die frage die mich
umtreibt das müsste uns jetzt eigentlich
ein regierungssprecher oder ein
lka-sprecher ganz genau beantworten ich
hatte das robert-koch-institut natürlich
auch angefragt und wollte wissen wie
viele von den insgesamt
215.000 toten corona toten die seit
beginn der pandemie vermeldet wurden
sind denn nun an können wie viele sind
mit grüner gestorben die antwort ist
relativ ernüchternd man hat die ganz
konkrete zahlen nicht oder man hat sie
uns zumindest nicht mitgeteilt man hat
gesagt aus dem robert-koch-institut hieß
es dass der großteil der menschen die
als crooner tote vermeldet wurden auch
tatsächlich die todesursache corona
hatten aber ich glaube ehrlich gesagt
man weiß dass nicht genau weil die
hälfte der bundesländer die zahlen gar
nicht kennt oder sie zumindest einfach
nicht nicht meldet sich nicht dafür
interessiert du stellst mehr transparenz
her danke dir mit meinem chef philipp
iad oft bei uns im studio